you were walking
[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
in the last robotics episode we took a
look at the most realistic robots in
terms of strictly interactional movement
now we're going to take a look at the
juicy stuff in this video we'll check
out the cutting edge of three categories
robotic dexterity versatility and
overall innovation let's begin with
dexterity when it comes to robotic
dexterity and athleticism there's no one
doing it better than Boston Dynamics the
company now owned by the Japanese firm
Softbank was founded in 1992 and has
since risen to become the leader in
robotics Atlas is a six foot humanoid
robot that's been designed for search
and rescue its abilities include
navigating outdoor rough terrain and
manipulating its environment in order to
sea Atlas is equipped with stereo
cameras and a laser rangefinder the
robot is so advanced that it can now do
some tasks that I'd say most humans
couldn't this includes successful
backflips when released in 2013
Atlas was an absolute breakthrough in
humanoid robotics as it could easily
walk on uneven surfaces and even
snow-covered terrain and it can get up
when knocked over this is something that
the previous generation of humanoid
robots couldn't manage maybe to put some
minds at ease the Department of Defense
has stated that it has no interest in
using this robot for offensive or
defensive warfare spot mini the k-9
inspired spot mini weighs about 25
kilograms or 55 pounds and is much
lighter than other Boston Dynamics
robots it runs off electricity and can
operate for about one and a half hours
spot mini is also the quietest robot
from Boston Dynamics in February 2018 a
videospot mini opening a door with a
claw made it to number one on YouTube
trendy and a lot of people did find it a
bit creepy especially if they're a fan
of black mirror but I really just see
good mechatronics engineering
so most of the footage that you've seen
a spot mini is when the robot is malt
anima smite but what some people might
not know is that spot meaning he can
actually be controlled by human he's a
pretty cool example of a TEDTalk where
that happens so this is Seth Davis who's
my robot Wrangler today and he's giving
spots some general direction by steering
it around but all the coordination of
the legs and the sensors is done by the
robots computers on board it's Scott or
a solid-state gyro and I am you on board
it loves to use its dynamic gates like
running and it's got one more some of
you may see that as a head in the neck
but believe me it's an arm and Seth is
driving it around now he's actually
driving the hand and the body is
following so the two are coordinated in
the way I was talking about before it
the way people can do that and in fact
one of the cool things that spa can do
we call chicken head mode and it keeps
its head head in one place in space and
it moves its body all around there's a
variation of this that's called twerking
so spot I'm feeling a little thirsty
could you get me a soda now for this
demo Seth is not using doing any driving
we have a lidar on the back of the robot
and it's using these props we put on the
stage to localize itself it's gone over
to that location now it's using a camera
that's in its and to find the cop picks
it up and again Seth's not driving so we
planned out a path for it to go it
looked like it was going off the path
and now it's that's going to take over
control again because I'm a little bit
chicken about having to do this by
itself
thank you spot
[Music]
[Applause]
feel about having just finished your Ted
performance me too
thank you all and thanks to the team at
Boston Dynamics we did all the hard work
behind another way but that Boston
Dynamics has is handle handle combines
the dexterity of other Boston Dynamics
robots but with wheels it stands six
point five feet high and can travel
about 15 kilometers an hour or nine
miles now it also runs on battery and
can travel a pretty impressive 24
kilometers or 15 miles in one charge and
to add to this it can jump four feet
high
[Music]
[Music]
versatility
Honda's a sumo robot takes the cake for
the most versatile robot in terms of
ease of integration into various target
market s MO which stands for advanced
step in innovative mobility has the
ability to make sense of its environment
via facial and sound recognition but
this goes a step further s mo can also
understand postures and gestures such as
handshakes pointing or waving this
enables the robot to interact with
humans quite well it's also capable of
detecting the movement of multiple
objects including distance and direction
this is achieved by two cameras and a
Simoes head acting as its eyes s mo can
follow a face alternates head to a
person when being approached or spoken
to the robot also has the ability to
recognize general sounds such as an
object falling or other loud noises
overall the robot is very
multifunctional and can perform a number
of general tasks such as turning on
light switches opening doors carrying
objects and pushing carts now let's take
a look at innovation this one comes from
the field of medicine is the da Vinci
robot I think it's a pretty good idea
the da Vinci system is robotic
technology that allows the surgeons hand
movements to be translated into smaller
more precise movements using tiny
instruments inside of the patient's body
the da Vinci has two parts a tower
whether robotic arm operates and a
separate console where it's been
controlled by the surgeon tower is
positioned directly over the patient
during surgery and is equipped with four
controlled computer arms three of them
have a wealth of surgical instruments
and the fourth is equipped with 3d
cameras at the console booth the surgeon
can operate the controls while looking
through a stereoscopic monitor this
monitor provides an HD 3d view of the
area being operated on the end result is
now hyper precise movement without human
artifacts such as shaking he is an
example of the system performing a mock
surgery on a grape
[Music]
in the medical field the da vinci is
currently used for cardiac surgery
general surgery head and neck surgery
urology surgery and various other
surgeries so finer and more controlled
movements surely have their advantages
but some critics know that the da Vinci
system ultimately limits the creative
freedom because the software can't be
altered by physicians so let's move from
the operating table to somewhere
completely different deep-sea
exploration and we'll start off by
Stanford's ocean 1 robot this robot is
pretty interesting
it's a humanoid Android that stands in
between a human diver and an autonomous
underwater vehicle
Stanford's ocean one robot is supposed
to dive into areas that are too
dangerous for humans and likely to be
damaged by traditional autonomous
vehicles areas such as coral reefs ocean
one is controlled by a human who
receives haptic feedback on the controls
when the robot touches something so the
next robot takes this idea a little bit
further it's a fish robot called sofa in
general we as humans know next to
nothing about the vast oceans on this
planet and the life that lives within it
for example the very first footage of
the elusive greenland shark which can
live for more than four hundred years
was only captured in 2011 one solution
is to have a robot that actually looks
like a convincing part of Wildlife so it
can swim close to you and study ocean
ecosystems without being detected MIT
researchers have recently just
successfully tested so fire in deep
diving and it can swim up to 40 minutes
at once it easily handled currents and
took high-resolution photos and videos
using a fisheye lens somewhat ironically
Robert Katzman is head of this research
at MIT his computer and science
artificial intelligence laboratory and
he says quote to our knowledge this is
the first robotic fish that can swim
underneath in three dimensions for
extended periods of time we are excited
about the possibility of being able to
use a system like this to get closer to
marine life than humans could ever get
on their own
end quote the scientists hope that
Sophia can shed some light on the oceans
deep mysteries staying on the topic of
animals
our next robot is a cat
open cat is an interesting approach to
robotics it's a low-budget yet capable
simple kit project for those wanting to
learn about robotics inventor wrong
Zhong Li explains quote we are
developing programmable and highly
maneuverable quadruped robots for STEM
education and AI enhance services its
compact and Bionic design makes it the
only affordable consumer robot that
mimics various mammal behaviors and
reacts to his surroundings its
innovative soft joints reduce wear or
shot and extends the lifetime of
Hardware end quote
there are two versions one that uses an
Adreno motion module for real-time
adaption and a full version which uses a
Raspberry Pi to enable AI enhanced
perception the PI brings Wi-Fi Bluetooth
and touch distance sensors voice and
night vision capabilities the project is
geared at the less taking client who
still want to have some fun and
something to play with
Li's states that the end goal would be
like a little robotic cat Alexa or
Android phone with an app store that you
can download third-party applications
and functions for he hopes the end price
will be about the same as the average
smartphone okay so this last one may not
be a perfect fit but I thought I'd chuck
it in these are robots whose sole
purpose are to create as much damage as
possible and no I'm not gonna be
revealing a secret rise of terminator
what I'm talking about is those backyard
build robots from battle bots in America
and robot wars in UK when I was about
seven or eight years old I used to adore
robot wars
in fact I've told you guys before that
the name of this channel was based on my
old high school band's name but even
before that cold fusion was the name of
a robot I built in primary school anyhow
I had a look at the new american version
of battle bots and it's come so far it's
almost like a sportin ways with
different strategies and excited
commentators as you can see there's some
insane effort put into some of these
machines
[Music]
but as far as pure destruction goes the
title for this category has to go to
Tombstone in the American series
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
so with that we've come to the end of
the video so which robot was your
favorite and why so to recap we have the
efforts from Boston Dynamics with almost
human-like balance and agility the
friendly robot from Honda a Simone the
surgical DaVinci robot that increase of
the technical abilities of surgeons
ocean 1 and Android diver Sophia a
swimming fish robot open cat aiming to
bring robotics to everyone and lastly
backyard built fighting robots let me
know in the comments section below so I
want to thank you guys for watching the
whole way through this video if you're
new here feel free to subscribe this has
been - go go you've been watching cold
fusion and I'll catch you again soon for
the next video cheers guys have a good
one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you